Britain blames Russia for the so spree
spy poisoning an attack that plunged
relations with Moscow into the deep
freeze
now it's emerged the same Russian
military intelligence unit allegedly
targeted UK and other NATO forces in
Afghanistan the GI use accused of
offering bounties to Taliban linked
militants for killing Allied troops
British officials deemed the analysis by
US intelligence to be credible and mp's
what Boris Johnson to take action so
serious is this that I'll be seeking an
urgent question on Monday and will be
encouraging the UK to raise this matter
at the United Nations and indeed with
our NATO allies it's so important that
we collectively stand up to where Russia
is heading
that also means here in the UK let's get
that Intelligence and Security Committee
back up and running let's publish the
overdue Russia report the Prime Minister
last year failed to approve publication
of a report into alleged Russian
meddling in the UK months have since
passed but the parliamentary committee
that can release the document has yet to
be reestablished questions to the
president Donald Trump on his
relationship with Russia the commander
in chief forced to deny claims in The
New York Times that he knew about the
Russian activity in Afghanistan
nobody briefed or told me vice president
pence or chief of staff mark meadows
about the so-called attacks on our
troops in Afghanistan by Russians he
tweeted nobody's been tougher on Russia
than the Trump administration
but the alleged threat to US forces in
Afghanistan perhaps suggests this tough
talk hasn't been deterring Moscow it is
evidence that the Russians are willing
to really push the envelope in terms of
highly aggressive and you know
completely sort of unethical practices
and it also seems to show that the
Russians are looking at a kind of
worldwide theater of battle in terms of
the places in which they feel that they
can target kind of Western assets and
Western interests president Putin's
government dismissed the claims as fake
news
the Taliban - issued a denial for
Afghanistan it's just another chapter in
this country's long war
Deborah Haynes Sky News